it appears that some of you are not
taking the Urgent threat of climate
change seriously enough which is why the
president of the United States wants to
remind you just how serious it really is
you know I've seen firsthand what the
reports make clear the devastating toll
of climate change and its existential
threat to all of us and is the ultimate
threat to humanity climate change the
ultimate threat I'm not sure if
President Biden really believes this I'm
not sure if Biden really believes
anything but plenty of people really do
believe this because we live in an
increasingly Pagan Age and what pagans
fear and worship ultimately is nature
that is why the old pagans the old timey
pagans would sacrifice goats and babies
and things to make it rain